Okay,
so when the final scene of kill bill
volume two by Quentin Tarantino,
the eponymous villain bill tranquilized
as the hero and the narrative to deliver
a short monologue on his deep affection
for comic book Superheroes,
namely Superman Man of steel,
he says,
stands apart from other heroes like that
man,
Spiderman,
etc.
In that,
unlike those others who have to don the
costume,
that they may become the hero,
superman wakes as superman and must
instead down the costume of clark at the
mild mannered reporter from the daily
planet who bill believes is superman's
critique on the human race.
Now,
I don't know if tarantino believes this
or it's just build who does,
but being a huge fan of superman.
I have to say that I can't agree with
this characterization of the last son of
crypto.
Not too long ago when I didn't have to
pay for rent or utilities or groceries
or car insurance.
I used to read comic books.
Every wednesday I go to the local comic
book store and pick up new editions of
the dc monthly.
It's mainly the for superman titles,
which were at that time still running
action comics,
superman,
the adventures of superman and the man
of steel.
I was the only one of my friends who who
read comics regularly and so it was sort
of a thrill going there every wednesday
because it was my first real sense of a
community in which everyone was
connected by their love of something.
In this case,
comics,
and I've been a huge fan of communities
like that ever since.
Hence.
Anyway,
I became fascinated with superman
probably for the same reason that a lot
of young boys do.
They get lost in that fantasy of
unlimited physical power.
superman could fly and it is an
immutable fact of the universe that
every boy everywhere knows exactly which
combination of muscles to clench in
order to take off into the sky or shoot
fire from your eyes or see through
walls.
Superman could do all those things.
He could fly at.
Super speed here,
cries for help at great distances.
He could pick up cars and hurl them like
baseballs and how cruel where the stupid
stupid laws of physics for preventing
all this regular humans from doing such
things when it's so easy to imagine.
I don't think that those fantasies ever
leave us,
but as I grew older,
the story of superman began to captivate
me for different reasons.
I think when we're young,
we feel that to achieve those feats of
strength would solve a lot of our
problems.
If I could only fly,
if I can be the one who flies,
then I could be special and important
and all those abstract things.
But as we make our way through
adolescence,
the complexities of the inner life begin
to muddy those waters.
The pen with which you have to write
your own identity,
gets put into your hand and you realize
that no feat of strength or speed will
help you with that task or superman.
The tasks would be even more difficult.
His strength,
his speed,
his ability to fly,
serve only to neutralize the physical so
that the intellectual and emotional
problems that plague all of us.
how to love,
how to be loved,
how to know who we are,
what we should want,
how we should act,
why we're here,
appear only in starker relief.
All his incredible power becomes an
equally helplessness.
Clark can't,
can't wake up fried from these things
just as neither you nor I can ignore the
personal and ethical dilemmas that
define us and it's ironic that in the
comics,
his feelings of being an alien from
another planet of not fitting in or the
cause of so much sorrow because it has
these same feelings of sorrow for not
fitting in,
for not belonging,
that make the rest of us human.
Clark kent is clark kent.
He puts on the costume to become
superman and his as godly and perfect as
we would have others believe that we
are.
He saves the world from extraterrestrial
existential threats,
from villains of every shape,
size and hairstyle.
Good.
He is as impotent as the rest of us when
it comes to saving himself from the
bumbling stuttering forever struggling
condition of life and maybe clark kent
is clark kent's critique on the human
race,
but to say that is simply to say that we
are all continuously critiquing the
human race.
When we,
for example,
make total fools of ourselves in front
of the lowest lanes of our lines and as
beautiful as lois seems to clark,
we know that she herself feels
inadequate and the presence of superman,
the great hero who is after all,
only the same clark kent,
who's invincible knees,
can't seem to keep from going week in
the presence of her kryptonite eyes.
Some critique.